ils fêteront l'an prochain leurs 30 ans
depuis 1988 manuela et son mari jir ce
commerce dans le centre ville de
maurepas un travail une passion
développé au gré des crises économiques
et du développement des zones
commerciales aujourd'hui les espère
profiter du nouveau fonds lancé par la
commune pour rénover leurs devantures
il commence à voir quand on a des pluies
qui sont un petit peu fort qu'un petit
peu d'infiltration donc on vise donc ça
fait déjà deux trois ans que je voulais
le faire mais par des problèmes
financiers
je ne le fais pas quand j'ai appris
qu'ils aient accès une première dans les
yvelines
pourquoi pas donc je remplirai le
dossier si ça passe tant mieux ça peut
toujours aider
voté fin mars en conseil municipal le
fond des doit permettre de soutenir les
commerces locaux dans la limite de trois
mille euros par dossier travaux de
rénovation d'embellissement ou encore de
sécurisation ce nouvel outil est une
première dans les yvelines donc sa
valise et soit resté ou soit à venir
justement dans des locaux vacants et
aussi dans le cadre d'une harmonisation
et d'une charte des enseignes parce
qu'on s'aperçoit qu'on a
des enseignes qui sont pas identiques en
fonction des commerces et donc on
travaille aussi la qualité esthétique
mais aussi la vétusté des vitrines donc
d'aider les commerçants dans cette
démarche pour bénéficier de l'aide
financière les commerçants maurepas
siens peuvent se rendre sur le site
internet de la ville ou directement en
mairie
les dossiers seront ensuite étudie par
une commission au total quinze mille
euros sont débloqués par la commune